wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
ja klar
was ist los alles in ordnung
warum ich sehe doch das ist nicht gut
geht
ja ich weiß ich habe vorhin ein bisschen
überreagiert
das war nicht meine frage lisa ich bin
schwanger
wow wow was soll ich denn jetzt machen
janina freu dich du bekommst und das ist
toll
da ist jetzt nicht die nerven verlieren
ach ja wer ist denn der vater mario er
seid doch erst seit ein paar wochen zu
sagen du musst es ihnen sagen ich weiß
was ich mache das kind war
wie soll ich das denn schaffen
ich kann ja jetzt kein kind erziehen
mann ich bin doch eine ausbildung kommen
es gibt kindergärten tagesmütter anderem
mit erschaffen das doch auch da ist er
nicht so viele sorgen machen
ich weiß nicht
eine ganz ganz tolle motive